Phoebe Cates was one of the biggest teen
stars of the 1980s after making her big
screen debut in the Blue Lagoon knockoff
paradise she starred in a string of
quintessential 80s movies including Fast
Times at Ridgemont High private school
and gremlins it looked like Cates was
here to stay until the mid-1990s when
she just kind of vanished here are the
real reasons Phoebe Cates disappeared
from Hollywood motherhood shortly after
her breakthrough role in Fast Times at
Ridgemont High Cates auditioned for more
adult roles including Chloe in the baby
boomer classic The Big Chill she didn't
get the part it went to meg tilly but
she got to meet one of the film stars
Kevin Kline they married in 1989 and now
have two children together a son named
Owen and a daughter Greta like a lot of
parents Cates decided that she preferred
focusing on raising a family to pursuing
a full-time career outside the home
string of bad luck the movies Kate
starred in toward the end of her working
years weren't exactly blockbusters
anyway despite being the long-awaited
sequel to a very popular movie gremlins
- the new batch took in a relatively
disappointing 41 million dollars in 1990
drop dead Fred made 13 million dollars
when it arrived in theaters the
following year and her final major film
the quirky 1994 comedy princess caribou
earned just 2.9 million dollars during a
disappointing theatrical run lack of
interest even though she was focused on
being a mom Cates didn't completely
retire her last major role was in the
2001 independent movie the anniversary
party
she took the part as a favor to the
director Jennifer Jason Leigh one of her
best friends since the two played pals
in Fast Times at Ridgemont High that
role is one of a small handful of
projects that Cates has deemed worthy of
leaving her kids at home to pursue
charity work Cates is son Owen has
juvenile diabetes since seeing its
effect firsthand Cates Incline devote a
lot of time effort and money toward
fundraising efforts to find a cure for
the metabolic disease among the
organizations Cate supports is the
Juvenile Diabetes Research Foundation
which puts on benefits like rock The
Cure and the promise ball to raise money
for research a new calling
Kate's lives in Manhattan's fancy Upper
East Side which is also where she
operates an upscale boutique called blue
tree the store started off selling
expensive designer toys but is expanded
to include clothing housewares and
specialty foods
she told the USA Today in 2006
I always wanted to have a general store
if I could have a photobooth Ansel's
candy I would have clearly cases opens
the idea of selling all kinds of things
at blue tree so would she sell a mocha
why then I'll give you $200 that's $200
I'm sorry
mo why not for sale oh well probably
better off thanks for watching subscribe
to our YouTube channel to watch more
videos like the one you just saw and
leave us a comment to let us know which
other 80 stars you'd love to see make a
comeback
[Music]